we now have some breaking news coming in
from new york city in the united states
the sentencing of the movie mogul harvey
weinstein who was convicted of sexual
assault and rape in the court we can go
now to discuss US correspondent amanda
miller who's there a 23 year prison
sentence for harvey weinstein Amanda
yeah this is certainly at the higher end
of possible sentencing the minimum was
five years maximum 29 years 23 years is
what Harvey Weinstein has been handed
down in this sentencing now the first
criminal sex act first degree that is 20
years in prison five years post-release
supervision and then for the second
charge rape in the third degree three
years in prison for a total of 23 now
Harvey Weinstein has been speaking
inside the sentencing hearing we
understand showing very little
contrition certainly no apology to the
women who have also been speaking in
there he referred to them saying I had
wonderful times with these people I
think men are confused about these
issues I'm worried about this country
lots of men like myself are the latest
examples he went on to say there are so
many people who would say great things
about me including 60 executives in the
industry so obviously that was his last
push to get a lighter sentence that's
what his defense team had been trying to
do saying that his basically remarkable
achievements is in terms of giving money
to charity his achievements in the movie
industry meant that he should get a
shorter sentence clearly the judge has
not heeded that handing down what is
certainly perhaps more than a lot of
people were expecting with the minimum
being five years he will has just been
given 23 year sentence